hi Rachel how are you fantastic thank
you right look you're about to be a
missus say it again a missus phrased it
to me like that before
it's Rachel Lindsay tell me about any of
the plans are are you ready I am ready
so I just announced on Instagram
literally today that it is summer 2019
that we're getting married the latter
part of the summer I have an
announcement official day yet it will be
a destination wedding in a warmer
location closer to Columbia where
Bryan's from but it's not in Columbia
and I'm excited I I was the bride who
always first of all I didn't call myself
a bride I was like I'm getting married
at a courthouse I want to keep it moving
once I find the guy that I want to spend
the rest of my life with as you can see
I did not go the traditional route so I
am doing things a little different than
I thought so I'm excited
I wanted a 50-person wedding we're
already at 150 girl Juli Baker go home
why not your your the problem for the
beautiful gown the large look why not I
I kind of am buying into the hive at
this point like I know who I want
deciding my dress so I'm gonna go with
Randi wrong she did the dress that I met
the guys in the first night she designed
the dress that Bryan proposed to me in
so it only makes sense that that's who I
go with to design my wedding dress that
I'm walking down the aisle to Bryan oh I
can't wait to see the pictures I know
you gotta look beautiful I'm very very
excited and it after like I don't even
recognize myself right now but it's fun
because we're getting started we're
hitting the ground running got to go to
New York get fitted I'm not going to
have bridesmaids maybe my sisters maybe
I must good messy
33 so at this point I would have like 15
bridesmaids and it's just too much so
you know I'll save that they'll be
Bachelorette maids for the party talk
about Colton do you have any advice for
Colton he is making it through he seems
a little stressed and some of the
trailers in the promo video so how do
you feel what is your advice to him so
I'm a bit behind by that I mean one
Episode wait its I feel like it's on
tonight okay so maybe three tonight
episodes now at this point I mean I just
feel like Colton needs to stick to who
he is and knows what he's mean it's he
needs to know what he wants and then I
feel like he can be better able to pick
the girl that he wants that's something
that you did as far as like your tactic
and I'm like yeah like Colton's what 26
at 26 I wouldn't have known what I was
wanting but he may be different and so I
just feel like when there's so much
outswing outside noise around you like
to to pressure to pick who you should
think you should pick or maybe who's
somebody else wants or whatever I just
like he needs to stay true to who to
himself and pick the person that he
wants that's really good advice mrs.
Rachel Lindsay okay so I know mrs. so
before I let you go because you
successfully you know have a husband or
if your future husband
what is something in your opinion two
things that men want in a relationship
okay I keep saying this I don't feel
like men know what they want that's what
Josh is he said the same thing Josh
Connor he said this I said you're smart
man
just a minute thank you men do not know
what they want women are here to help
them figure out what it is they need
they want like you know we're the neck
that's what they say right we we tell
them to turn left right front back
whatever it is and like that's what I
feel like men know what they want when
we help them figure it out we let them
think they figured it out by themselves
but they really didn't we know we did it
and that's a woman's job I expected to
see that in the movie today I'm so
excited for it so nice to meet you
have a good night thank you
[Music]